non
rocard non non je râle tenter d'arranger
un toubib fond
non
triquint comme dirait le keirin
parce que vous me dites un deuxième
volet je veux bien mais bon et je les
cache pour moi et les autres je donne à
ses clients
pour un grand prix du festival de cannes
on ne pouvait demander à quelqu'un de
très important de venir avec nous et
voici monsieur alfred hitchcock
grand prix international du festival de
cannes 1972
le jury a tenu à récompenser deux
réalisateurs pour l'ensemble de leur
oeuvre et souligner la qualité
exceptionnelle de l'interprétation de
zhai maria volontè ex-aequo à
l'unanimité la sphère rap et de
francesco rosi
et la greffe brière va encore à 10,2
elio pétri ical
ainsi une fois de plus le cinéma
français sort grand perdant de la
compétition cannoise
même si le prix d'interprétation accordé
à jean yanne mais quelques pommes sur
une blessure d'amour propre
comment expliquer cela constatant
d'abord que les deux grands prix
attribué ex-aequo à la fermeté et la
classe ouvrière va au paradis couronne
deux oeuvres celles de rosie et celle de
pétri qui sont profondément marqués par
notre temps qui expriment les problèmes
fondamentaux de notre époque à savoir la
difficile conciliation de l'autorité de
la démocratie par l'affirmative la
condition ouvrière dans la classe
ouvrière va au paradis
en face qu'au fond nous des films
intimistes qui se borne à narrer les
déchirements du couple pour pouvoir
atteindre en public les cinéastes
français pensent qu'il convient de faire
commercial or il est pas nécessairement
prouver qu'un film commercial très un
film qui refuse d'être ambitieux il faut
donc que les auteurs et du courage et
que les producteurs en france
comprennent que leur intérêt va souvent
de pair avec les grands sujets de la
saur peut être le cinéma français dont
un a évoqué récemment sur cette antenne
la crise actuelle pourra-t-il sortir de
l'ornière ici cannes informations
première